بعض الاشخاص لم يجلب لهم اشباههم سوى
المتاعب وهذه قصصهم
مثلا قصه العثور على جثه امراه شابه في
اغسطس الماضي في سياره متوقفه في المانيا
تعرفت عليها عائلتها على انها العراقيه
شربانكي البالغه من العمر 23 عاما ولكن
بعد تشريح الجثه تبين ان الضحيه هي خديجه
مدونه جزائريه تواصلت معها شربان وقتلتها
للتظاهر بالموت ثم جاء ابريل حكم على
روسيا فيكتوريا البالغه من العمر 47 عاما
بالسجن لمده 21 عاما لسرقه هويه شبيهتها
الامريكيه
بما في ذلك جواز السفر بعد ان سممتها في
منزلها
كما ادين رجل يدعى
بالسرقه وقضى 17 عاما في السجن بالفعل
ولكن بعد ان عرض على شهود جنبا الى جنب مع
مشتبها به اخر لم يتمكن الشهود من التفريق
بينهما فالغى القاضي ادانته
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات